Bolivian President Evo Morales has hit
back after his journey to his home
country was disrupted justifying
protests I would like to tell you that
we will now give Edward Snowden asylum
by his compatriots we are not afraid
Morales was held up in Austria after
several European countries denied his
plane permission to enter their airspace
they suspected Snowden was on board the
flight from Moscow where he is currently
stranded he remains in the transit zone
at Sheremetyevo Airport he flew to
Russia from Hong Kong almost two weeks
ago after admitting to leaking
information about secret American
surveillance programs
now several countries have offered
asylum game of Esav Edom
we have decided to offer Snowden the
international humanitarian right to
asylum we do so to protect him from the
persecution that has been unleashed from
the most powerful imperialist country in
the world against a young man who only
spoke the truth
Nicaraguan President Daniel Ortega also
suggested his country would accept
Snowden's application we are an open
country respectful of the right to
asylum it is clear that its
circumstances permit we will happily
receive Snowden who wants asylum here in
Nicaragua a seal or King Nicaragua
questions still remain over whether
Snowden would be allowed to travel his
passport has been withdrawn while the
debacle over Morales flight shows that
any plane he boards could be grounded